John boyega you my nose always say my
name like that you know giving it all he
got his Star Wars cash and he I don't
know where you hit but you hit a shot a
wonderful shot
yeah and you were bought some stuff so
yeah you very kindly brought some
pictures of some of the things your your
bed at the bottom of your bed what have
you got I've got some lions sculptures
and with lions those are like drinkers
compared to what else has got you but
the reason why I bought that is because
I feel like my spirit animal is a lion I
just feel that you know I am African I
am yes the Lions yes how did you buy the
saxophone lamp there's no reason for
that man you know that was glorified
nonsense I can't like see no I mean I
mean I was in Australia and this dude
you just told me that there's there's a
saxophone with a light bulb with it yeah
something in my brain said to me by I
made a lamp out of my father's clarinet
so well there's a we have a thing it has
something to do with some thing that we
have we share your like a lion
I liked I'm like a lion kind of yeah I
could do that you have a saxophone lamp
and I have a marionette line yeah cool
can I just ask you do you have a more
attractive bulb in yours
it's environment then as you know you've
been in the bedroom with now I don't
where that is but we've walked past that
that's my living room and where do we
find this that's in the corridor okay
now just quite off gum tree or something
okay it's it's just a replica of a
Spartan helmet and okay I did it come
with the plinth or did you buy that
separate now I bought that separately
[Applause]
I'm just a big fan of weird things I
told you I'm 73 deep though you're in so
you've seen the lines you're excited the
saxophone lab is brilliant I really
enjoy that house on the way to the
toilet give it to you get into the loo
okay you sit down uh-huh you do your
business you need a little bit of toilet
paper in John's house this is who gives
it to you boom
[Applause]
you're jealous huh you're all jealous
things like going over there as a girl
you know they go in the bathroom you're
just like that's a red flag
[Applause]
[Music]